the scrolls have been around for a very
long time in Marvel Comics first making
their appearance in 1962 in Fantastic
Four number two and now they're finally
making their appearance in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe next year in Captain
Marvel we got our first look at them in
the Captain Marvel teaser trailer as one
of the villains in the movie so who
exactly are these new villains and why
are they so dangerous in this video I'll
be talking about their origins and some
of their abilities that make them such a
threat also my giveaway still continues
giving away copies of infinity war and
ant-man and the wasp on blu-ray and some
special edition posters all you have to
do to enter for your chance to win is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero as
I mentioned before the scrolls have been
around in the Marvel Comics universe for
a very long time in fact they are
considered the oldest Empire in the
universe's history they were actually a
very primal and peaceful race that is
until the Celestials showed up and did
experiments on them these experiments
caused the scrolls to be split into
three different races the Eternals the
normals and the deviants once the
Celestials left the deviants actually
ended up murdering the other two
squirrel races leaving the deviants to
be the only remaining squirrel race
these girls go on to have a very long
lasting war with the Kree the first war
started because the scrolls decided to
pit two races of Halle against each
other the Kree and the catotti the
scrolls actually began to light the
Cotati and in turn the Kree murdered all
of the catotti and then attacked the
scroll and stole their technology
starting a galactic war we know that
we're going to see some type of Kree
scroll war in Captain Marvel however
since Kevin Feige has said that this is
not going to be a typical origin movie
they may not follow the origin in the
comics completely unfortunately for
humans the scrolls believe that the
earth belongs to them so they
continually tried to infiltrate and
attack earth something that we did see
in the Captain Marvel teaser trailer as
well
so what makes them such a huge threat to
earth Captain Marvel the Fantastic Four
and the Avengers well the biggest thing
is that they can shape-shift they can
shape-shift into any human being
male or female perfectly not only that
but they can shape-shift into animals
and inanimate objects making it to where
you never know who or what is a scroll
unless the scroll reveals itself to you
if this wasn't enough they've also
genetically augmented themselves
creating the super scroll and the wor
Scrolls they did this through their
technology as I mentioned in the
beginning they're one of the oldest
empires in the Marvel Comics universe so
needless to say they've had some time to
tinker with their technology the super
scroll is a beast it has all the
abilities of the Fantastic Four plus the
ability to shape-shift
he's a recurring character in the comics
and eventually goes on to become emperor
of the scrolls and then you have war
Scrolls as I mentioned before war
Scrolls are the product of genetic
experimentation and have powers that go
beyond the typical scroll not only can
war Scrolls shape-shift but they can
also imitate people's powers so not only
could one of them look exactly like the
Human Torch but they could also use his
powers and flame on this makes them an
extreme threat to the Avengers due to
the fact that they can infiltrate the
Avengers imitate one of the heroes and
the Avengers could have no idea who the
real one is which is what happens in the
secret war story so not only will Carol
Danvers have to deal with the Kree in
Captain Marvel but she'll also have to
go against the scrolls were Skrulls and
probably the super scroll in Captain
Marvel so that's it for this video on
the origins and abilities of the scrolls
what do you all think about these new
enemies coming into the MCU and do you
think any of the current heroes could be
Scrolls let me know your thoughts in the
comments below and don't forget to
subscribe comment and like the video so
you can enter the giveaway and stay up
to date on everything relating to
Captain Marvel Avengers 4 and marvel
comics as always thank you all so much
for watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]